what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have some thor love and thunder
and black panther news and i'm not
talking about two separate reports but
one report involving both franchises
that's right it looks like we're going
to have a crossover between the thor
love and thunder franchise and the black
panther franchise although this wouldn't
be the first time after all we did get
one of the greatest scenes in mcu
history when thor arrived in wakanda
[Music]
[Music]
so if that's what we're about to get
more of i am totally here for this but
this report is actually pretty exciting
and the crossover is perhaps not what
you would really expect but it fits
within the story of thor love and
thunder perfectly so let's go ahead and
break it all down and if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on all the latest mcu news so this
is quite interesting actually now thor
love and thunder is going to be
introducing more gods it's confirmed
that russell crowe is going to be in
thor love and thunder and he is going to
be playing zeus i think most people know
zeus from greek mythology he's going to
be in thor love and thunder and if we're
going to see zeus we might see some
other greek gods and goddesses as well
but the point is it is confirmed that
they are introducing more gods and then
we're going to be having christian bell
playing gore the god butcher and we'll
probably get somewhat of an origin story
on him as well much like we did hella in
thor ragnarok whereas she killed
valkyries we're probably going to see
gore killing other gods so the gods are
coming and it looks like they're also
going to be introducing a black panther
god but not in the way you think because
we've actually already seen this god in
the very first black panther film
however this time it's going to be way
different it looks like the actress
akosia sabet has been cast as the
goddess bastet who is more commonly
referred to as bast now we have seen
bast before in the first black panther
film she is the panther goddess that led
a warrior shaman to the heart-shaped
herb where he became the first black
panther to unite the five tribes of
wakanda to live in constant war with
each other until a warrior shaman
received a vision from the panther
goddess bust who led him to the heart
shaped earth
a blend that granted him superhuman
strength
speed and instincts now in this clip the
goddess was a black panther however
probably in thor love and thunder she is
going to be taking on a human shaped
form which of course will be the form of
the actual actress akosia sabet but it
is very interesting that they are
introducing a black panther goddess in
thor love and thunder and it's actually
kind of important as well it says a lot
about the direction that the mcu is
heading and she also has connections to
other gods including konchu the moon god
who we just recently saw in the moon
knight teaser so let's talk about what
her role could be in thor love and
thunder and what this could mean for the
future of the mcu so this was originally
reported by the cosmiccircus.com they
found a listing for her character on
showcast and on imdb both stating that
her role in thor love and thunder and
her character is going to be best now
why would she be in thor love and
thunder well like i mentioned they're
going to be introducing different gods
and it looks like they're going to be
bringing in different mythologies as
well we know zeus is going to be there
obviously bast is a black panther
goddess but gore the god butcher really
isn't going to see any difference
between any gods and he's going to go
out there and basically hunt down gods i
mean that is why he's called gore the
god butcher so it seems like gore might
actually be a huge threat as he might be
going around killing gods and i'm
predicting that there might be some type
of counsel of the gods now of course
thor is the god of thunder and whether
he likes it or not gore is probably
coming after him whether that's thor
getting involved in some type of a
council between the gods or whether gore
has had some type of past with him or
odin who knows but we are going to see
some godly fights here which will
probably lead to some pretty cinematic
scenes now also keep in mind that asgard
is now currently on earth and obviously
wakanda is on earth as well now we don't
know where the goddess bast resides we
don't know where she is if she's on
earth or if she's in a different astral
plane of some sort but thanks to that
opening scene in black panther we do
know that the black panther goddess was
physically on earth that's how she was
able to physically give the heart-shaped
herb to the shaman so wherever she may
reside she is going to be physically
present on earth and we probably are
going to get a look at wakanda in thor
love and thunder which will be
interesting to see because of the
passing of chadwick boseman will they
address this in thor love and thunder
will they say that king t'challa has
passed away will they say that there is
a new king of wakanda who knows but
there is going to be a crossover here
with wakanda in thor love and thunder
which is very very exciting and i'm very
excited to see bast the black panther
goddess and hopefully more gods fighting
together against gore the god butcher
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below do you
think this is going to be a cool
crossover or would you rather them not
really focus on this let me know down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the mcu for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof